hey guys Eric here to show you something
cool that happened to me in the division
last night after the maintenance was
over I headed back into the dark zone to
start my new grunt as I was making my
way through the dark zone I heard
gunfire and proceeded to head to the
location to help my fellow division
agents take out some riders or Ryker's
to my surprise though there are cleaners
actually fighting records this is the
first time I've seen this type of event
in the dark zone so either I hit a dark
zone at level threshold that unlock
these events or maybe these events were
set in motion after a certain amount of
time had passed either way this is
really cool to see and reminds me a lot
of destiny when you would see the high
fighting the Fallen on earth at sky
watch also it seems like there are more
enemies scattered throughout the dark
zone than previously seen I tend to run
into more small skirmishes which I enjoy
a lot more than going to landmark
locations that have been cleared out
tell me of you who experienced this yet
in the dark zone and your thoughts in
the comments below stay tuned to games
for more division content and news